sarà capitato a tutte le generazioni
prima della nostra di pensare di
trovarsi nel periodo più complesso della
storia del mondo
devo dire che anche il nostro periodo
non ne vale prima di tutto direi che c'è
una grandissima velocità
tutto si muove molto velocemente intorno
a noi si muovono velocemente le merci si
muovono velocemente le informazioni
anche noi ci muoviamo molto velocemente
ieri sera abbiamo calcolato che ci
saranno dodici minuti da bologna a
milano di cui 7 per salire a scelta
c'è poi una grande varietà i nostri
nonni se ci pensate nascevano in un
certo posto
lavoravano lì crescevano lì sempre lo
stesso gruppo di amici insomma un
circolo piuttosto chiuso ora noi siamo
esposti continuamente a a tutto se verrà
nell'era globalizzata quindi tutto
arriva e se non siamo noi che andiamo in
giro a cercarci questa varietà e allo
stesso modo questa cosa qua ci sta
arrivando non in maniera leggera ma ci
sta arrivando proprio comandata molto
forte ed è all'interno di questa
complessità c'è una piccola bussola che
ci guida una piccola parte cognitiva e
cioè la nostra capacità di prendere
decisioni
ogni giorno prendiamo decine di
decisioni centinaia alcuni dicono
migliaia alcuni sono molto veloci alcune
particolarmente più lente
alcune sono semplici altre molto
importanti ci vuole ci vuole tempo ci
vuole ragionamento
e noi non sappiamo bene quale di queste
decisioni alla fine avranno un vero
impatto sul nostro futuro sul futuro del
nostro paese della nostra azienda
neanche a me capitò una quindicina
d'anni fa via dover prendere una di
queste decisioni ai tempi era un giovane
ingegnere informatico per la genova
nella mia città e ricevetti un
interessante offerta lavorativa qua
dall'emilia romagna e quindi da un lato
avevo il mio lavoro di quel tempo molto
interessante devo dire è una bella sfida
invece qua in emilia a genova con la
famiglia mi ero appena sposato un mutuo
insomma tutte le cose che abbiamo tutti
dall'altra parte però una regione che
poteva sicuramente dare di più sia me
che i miei figli mentre facevo tutti
questi ragionamenti mi accorsi come in
effetti decidere mettendo informazioni
aggiungendo dati è molto più complicato
che decidere per come mi viene in quel
momento
alla fine comunque in qualche modo
decisi e quindi mi trasferì e mi
trasferii qua in emilia in particolare a
maranello per lavorare in formula 1 in
ferrari e capii subito che non sarebbe
stato facile nel senso che la ferrari è
veramente la tradizione veramente alla
tradizione della motorvalley a
tradizione dell'emilia grande competenza
roba molto hard quindi motori pistoni
benzina e io e le persone come me alla
fine che cosa portano come informatici
un sacchetto di una roba di trasparente
molto leggera che sono i dati che sono i
programmi gli algoritmi cioè il modo con
cui i dati vengono elaborati dai
compiuti
immaginate di dover discutere appunto
quelli ingegneri che hanno questa grande
esperienza che sono in grado di capire
come va la macchina non sto ascoltando
il suono del motore o delle gomme che
stridono in una curva o guardando il
posteriore della macchina in frenata no
che si muove movimenti che noi i più non
possono percepire ma loro da quello
riescono a capire per esempio l'assetto
della macchina
ebbene cosa facevamo raccoglievamo tutte
le informazioni dalla vettura
dei programmi e gli portavamo queste
informazioni
immaginatevi insomar da una parte la
loro competenza la loro capacità di
intuizione dall'altra parte tutti questi
dati insomma a volte le cose erano in
accordo e quindi quello che dicevano i
dati era quello che loro carceri vano a
volte no e non so se avete mai pensato
ma la nostra capacità di decidere è una
cosa che è nata noi l'abbiamo dai secoli
di evoluzione della nostra storia cioè
noi reagiamo sempre sostanzialmente due
modi attacco o fuga
se mancano di queste cose qua c'è
fingersi morti che anche quella nata
tica che ogni tanto funziona però quella
è la cosa che facciamo e quindi quando
ci troviamo comunque anche decidere con
i dati
queste cose qua entrano
quello che ho scoperto solo dopo è che
la formula 1 tende a essere una specie
di macchina del tempo cioè quello che
succede lì succedeva lì e l'inizio di
anni duemila in effetti sarebbe successo
a tutti noi nel mondo normale dopo 5 10
15 anni e quindi questa che viene
chiamata la d'età revolution la
rivoluzione dei dati cioè noi siamo
stati un certo punto invasi siamo stati
sommersi da una quantità di dati
veramente molto grande e da nuove
tipologie di dati e di internet e
abbiamo già parlato comunque la capacità
e la possibilità di andare ad aggiungere
informazioni ovunque nel mondo con tre
click mi sembra che ha detto stamattina
poi arrivare nei social network e social
network oltre che a cambiare in qualche
modo per certi versi alla nostra vita
portarono una nuova tipologia di dato
cioè il dato della conversazione questa
conversazione che prima veniva a casa
nostra nel bar a in un gruppo comunque
ristretto di persone improvvisamente era
messa
diciamo in pubblico era disponibile io
potevo posso discutere oggi con
tantissime persone del mondo e posso
parlare di quello che voglio posso
parlare per esempio dei prodotti delle
vostre aziende quindi il potere che
avevate voi una volta nelle vostre
aziende di avere di sapere bene il
vostro prodotto quello che pensava
perché noi consumatori né pensassimo
bene in effetti ora è là fuori perché là
fuori che la gente confronta che dice
questo mi piace questo non mi piace
un altro tipo di dato che arriva intorno
appunto al 2010 un pochettino prima fu
dato portato da queste cose qua gli
smartphone non so se lo sapete negli
ultimi tre mesi dell'anno scorso solo la
apple ha venduto più iphone di quanti
bambini sono nati nel mondo nello stesso
periodo per dare una dimensione del
fenomeno
avere un iphone in tasca cosa vuol dire
che qualcheduno ora sa dove sono come
sono venuto questa mattina dove mi sono
fermato a fare colazione dove sono
andato a mangiare eccetera eccetera
quindi questo dato chiama dato
geografico e un nuovo dato che è
arrivato a disp la disposizione
come tutte le rivoluzioni
diciamo si chiamano rivoluzioni perché
noi non siamo pronti quando arrivano noi
siamo pronti a recepire non siamo pronti
culturalmente non è pronta la tecnologia
e quindi all'inizio non fu facile
successero delle cose un po strane voi
forse ricorderete questo progetto che si
chiama prisma pare un progetto della
sicurezza americana pare che aveva
l'obiettivo di raccogliere le
informazioni da tutti i siti in da tutti
i social network da informazioni
telefoniche quindi le nostre
conversazioni metterle insieme per fare
fare qualcosa ma pensate anche come è
cambiata la nostra la nostra vita ora
andato a comprare un televisore
entrate e c'è un muro di 50 televisori
anche iniziato a guardare un po qualche
qualche etichetta e dice no ora vado a
casa e cerco su google
andate a casa cercate su google ei
televisori da 50 diventano 500
probabilmente 5000 è già lì panico
quando forse avete individuato quello
che vi piace iniziate andare a leggere i
commenti e quindi c'è il fan del vostro
televisore e cioè quello che dice mai
più un televisore di questa marca non
funziona il supporto è stato
schifosissimo insomma vi trovate un
attimino bloccati diciamo ma l'asta cosa
sta avvenendo è avvenuta nelle aziende o
nelle amministrazioni e cioè c'è una
riunione una persona deve prendere una
decisione
gli arrivano delle informazioni inizia a
dire interessante ma vorrei saperne di
più mi portate degli altri dati perché
non ho capito dopo una settimana
arrivano i dati
cavolo bello questo cosa ci fosse questa
altra informazione potrai decidere
meglio e via così quindi decisioni che
si prendevano in mezz'ora ora richiedono
settimane queste si chiama analysis
paralysis cioè la paralisi da troppa
analisi non so se vi ricorda
qualcosa
ebbene per fortuna nello stesso periodo
c'era qualcuno che aveva voglia di
iniziare a pensare come invece
utilizzare queste informazioni in questo
momento un po buio della storia quel
dato diciamo per ottenere un risultato
positivo in particolare
due giovani ricercatori proprio qua a
bologna erano in un centro di ricerca e
stavano studiando dei sistemi che erano
nati negli stati uniti da poco e che si
chiamavano sistemi tuttora si chiamano
sistemi di data warehouse cioè sistemi
tecnicamente vuol dire magazzino dei
dati quindi un posto dove voi mettete le
informazioni le correlate fra di loro i
dati e
quello che viene fuori sono delle
informazioni che vi servono per decidere
meglio bè diciamo un po per talento e un
po per fortuna erano nella regione
giusta nella città giusta ce la fa a
bologna e trovarono subito delle aziende
che avevano voglia di rischiare di fare
un percorso con i dati perché lavorare
con i dati un po lavorare con i bambini
bisogna andare per gravi ai dati si
possono fare delle domande ma dovete
fare delle domande facili all'inizio per
avere delle risposte di valore ma potete
poi pian pianino fare domande più
difficile avere risposte molto più di
valore e quindi la prima cosa che fecero
era uscire dall'università del centro di
ricerca fare la startup quindi andava
sono andati nei garage perché le sta
provando nei garage e hanno iniziato a
fare appunto a lavorare a crescere con
queste aziende
la prima cosa che io posso chiedere un
dato è di descrivervi una certa
situazione descrive mi quello che sta
succedendo e quindi vi faccio un esempio
pensate una regione chiave la necessità
di fare spendin review ahimé sui costi
della kerber nella medicina del servizio
sanitario però lo voglia fare in maniera
così minimizzando la
sofferenza per noi per le persone e
quindi pensate che informazioni a una
regione che tanto sa dove siamo quindi
immaginate di questa cartina i puntini
di dove viviamo poi sa ovviamente dove
sono gli ospedali dove sono tutti i
centri diagnostici ma soprattutto sa
perché alla storia delle cartelle
cliniche dove noi siamo andati a fare i
vari esami le varie operazioni e quindi
può studiare solo mettendoli su questa
mappa in qualche modo incrociandoli può
studiare come noi ci muoviamo per andare
negli ospedali perché non è detto che io
siccome sono qua vado nello spedale poi
diciamo magari il mio il mio paese va da
un'altra parte perché per qualche motivo
e quindi iniziando a mettere sopra su
questa mappa anche i costi posti liberi
eccetera ecco che l'amministrazione
pubblica può per esempio solo perché i
dati li descrivono il suo mondo fare
le sue valutazioni
una domanda più complicata che possiamo
fare ai dati e di spingersi avanti e
quindi andare verso la possibilità di
qualche modo predire un pochettino il
futuro e quindi supponete per esempio di
avere una catena di negozi e voleva
aprire un negozio da qualche parte un
punto vendita in italia e che
informazione avete intanto sapete quello
che siamo allo scontrino medio cioè la
persona mediamente quanto spende nel
vostro negozio diciamo 10 euro a sto
punto con qualche piccolo
device
elettronico voi per poter contare quante
persone entrano nel vostro negozio e
quindi voi sapete per esempio che ogni
dieci persone che entrano uno compra per
10 euro è già un informazione che
metteteli poi iniziate dire ok voglia
aprire il mio negozio a bologna le
informazioni potete raccogliere dal
fuori della vostra azienda per esempio
potete raccogliere delle informazioni
che dicono se una certa zona è una zona
dove ci sono abitazioni dove ci sono
uffici magari può fare la differenza per
il vostro tipo di negozio potete sapere
il reddito medio di quella zona anche
quelle sono informazioni disponibili
anche questo potrebbe fare la differenza
potreste sapere se ci sono competitor
nostri competitori vicini ma andando
addirittura sulla strada potreste anche
sapere quante persone fisicamente
passano passerebbero davanti alla vostra
vetrina
ecco che sapendo quante persone passano
davanti alla vostra vetrina quanto
entrano e ognuna di queste quanto più o
meno
spenderà nel vostro negozio potete
capire che in qualche modo potete
predire quale sarà la performance del
vostro negozio se lo pose rete
idealmente in quella via
de voi immaginate quando io incontrai
questi due ragazzi che nel frattempo
avevano fatto ai consulting l'azienda
dove lavoro che ormai era sì ma in tutta
italia un pochettino più di una start up
e anche all'estero
io vi diciamo la possibilità di portare
tutto quello che avevo imparato sulla
mia competenza la mia cultura sul dato
sulle applicazioni po fuori dal mercato
e chiamiamolo così della formula 1 per
qualche cosa di diverso e quindi
passiamo un pomeriggio ricordo con
federico pensa la
passare un pomeriggio a cercare di
pensare a come andare oltre a ciò che
altre anche altre domande possono
rispondere ai nostri dati e una domanda
sicuramente molto sfidante a quella di
predire di immaginarsi scenari che oggi
non sono pensabili quindi può fare un
doppio salto del futuro ed equa pensate
per esempio a una città che voglia
diminuire il numero di crimini
ok quindi che informazioni a una città
dal punto a quel punto di vista intanto
conosce realmente la topologia e sa dove
sono tutti i vari dipartimenti di
polizia poi sa dove ogni singola
macchina perché c'è un gps a bordo della
macchina come cesso nostro telefonino e
quindi voi sapete esattamente ogni
macchina dove in alcuni stati hai anche
in italia i poliziotti hanno un gps ad o
su una radio quelli che camminano per le
strade e quindi sapete anche dove sono i
singoli poliziotti
poi quella sapete sapete tanto tutti i
crimini degli ultimi anni quindi voi
potete dire che in certe zone ci sono
stati mediamente più crimini di che
natura in più in tempo reale voi potete
sapere se ci sono temporale potete
sapere se ci sono delle piazze se ci
sono dei cosiddetti punti di interessi
la stazione la scuola e in tempo reale
potete aggiungere informazioni tipo che
sta succedendo un certo tipo di evento
da qualche parte o anche banalmente che
ci sono spenti dei lampioni in una certa
zona della vostra città
ed ecco che un sistema intelligente un
algoritmo una serie di algoritmi
potrebbe in qualche modo teleguidare le
vostre forze dell'ordine nella città
proprio per passare in anticipo in tutti
quei punti dove preso abilmente potrebbe
esserci un reato e quindi diminuire la
probabilità che quel reato avvenga
è quello che sto cercando di raccontarvi
è sostanzialmente un nuovo oracolo
l'oracolo nel nel passato aveva il suo
intuito la sua parte umana poi cosa
faceva capretto
viscere del capretto volo di uccelli e
diceva il futuro sarà così
diciamo che il nostro nuovo oracolo che
cambiamo che chiamiamo d'età scientist e
cioè scienziato del dato a una base un
pochettino più solida diciamo in
particolare a tre componenti importanti
diciamo tre colori la prima sicuramente
quella della competenza tecnica la
competenza tecnologica sul dato quindi
la capacità di analizzare i dati
capacità che oggi devo dire di pochi ma
tempo come andremo in 12 minuti a milano
tempo pochi anni diciamo che
probabilmente tutti saremo in grado di
essere dei piccoli d'età scientist
appunto nel nostro piccolo e di prendere
delle decisioni basate sui dati in
maniera autonoma un altro importante
competenza un altro importante colore è
la conoscenza del business cioè se voi
volete risposte dai dati e risposte
cambiano senso dovete fare domande che
abbiano senso quindi domande che hanno
senso per voi per il vostro business per
la collettività per per la città dove di
rete
ma è la terza gamba al terzo colore che
quello che fa la differenza perché fra
un buon dato è una buona decisione
esiste un elemento non neutro chi è il
decisore che è l'uomo è solo l'uomo può
farci passare da quello che è una
descrizione al fatto che i dati scriva
nel mondo grazie